in this video we're going to talk about
different ways of structuring an economy
in particular who owns what and how does
an economy decide what to produce and
who gets the the output of that
production so on one side you have
what's known as a command economy and
good examples of command economies are
the communist States especially during
the 20th century the USSR the Soviet
Union being the best example of that and
a command economy the government
controls what's often known as the
factors of production and sometimes in
an extreme case there might not even be
private ownership so let's say that this
right over here is the government I'll
do this with some type of a building
with pillars in it so this is the
government and in a command economy the
government will often own the factories
and the farms so the factors of
production so let me draw a little
factory here so little smokestack and so
the government will tell this factory
you this year you have to produce
exactly ten thousand cars no more and no
less
and so that factories say ok you're our
boss you're the government we will
produce exactly ten thousand cars
similarly the government might tell some
let's say that this right over here is a
farm and this is my best drawing of a
field really fast and so it used to say
hey you need to produce I don't know 10
million apples I don't even know if
that's a reasonable amount of apples to
produce but you need to produce 10
million apples and so the farmers who
essentially work for the government
because the government would own that
farm they would produce those apples and
also in a command economy there's like
well who gets these cars and who gets
these apples well in an extreme command
economy they will be directly allocated
by the government the government will
say all right you get a car you get a
car you get a car and it might not be
based and in fact it it will not likely
be based on any type of who's willing to
pay for the car or who could pay the
most for the car similarly for the
apples so they're all going to be
allocated so there would have to be a
lot of planning done on the pie
of the government to say okay how much
should we produce of one thing versus
another thing and how do we decide who
gets the different things now the other
side of the spectrum you have what's
known as a market economy and most
economies in the world especially the
United States are much closer to being a
market economy than being a command
economy rather than having the
government owning the factors of
production deciding who produces what
and how much and who gets those things
and a market economy it's all based on
the factory right over here independent
of the government for the most part
unless you're in certain fact fields
that might have strong influence from
the government let's say you're a
military contractor but if you're not in
one of those fields if you're fairly
independent of the government what they
would say is well what is the market
need they might say hey look the market
needs 5,000 cars that look like this but
then it also needs another 2,000 trucks
that look like that and how are they
basing it well they might have looked in
the past year well how well is this car
selling how well the trucks selling they
might look at competitors in fact it in
a market economy you'll often have more
competition the command economies you
might have one really ginormous factory
that's owned by the government or a few
while here you might have competing
factories where they're always hey they
may they make a pretty good car we're
going to make one that's just as good
and it comes in yellow so once again you
have this notion of competition for
people to produce things out in the
market and they're also making their
best judgment of what does the market
actually need similarly you could have
your farmers here and you say hey you
know what I've been growing a lot of
apples but that doesn't seem to be in
demand anymore so I'm going to grow more
I don't know peaches because it looks
like the sale of peaches the peaches are
in fashion this year and similarly who
gets these is not dictated by the
government it's determined by the market
and so let's say this is me let's say
this is you let's say this is someone
else if I might not be interested in
getting a truck but I really need to get
a new car for my family so I can drive
them or
around and take vacations and things and
so and let's say you want to get a car -
but the market will dictate who gets it
so for example the factory might set a
price for this car they might say it is
ten thousand dollars per car and maybe
I'm willing to pay it maybe I'm not
maybe I was like well I really like that
blue car but I'm not willing to pay ten
thousand dollars and this yellow car is
available for nine thousand dollars so I
am going to get that and the prices
themselves won't necessarily be fixed if
they're not selling enough of these cars
at ten thousand dollars they might lower
the price to compete with the yellow car
at nine thousand dollars
similarly if there's a ton of people who
are willing to pay the price of this
truck
they might raise the price on the truck
or produce more of it and the severe
competition
if one firm doesn't do this well on a
regular basis they might go out of
business
so there's a strong motivation to be
able to meet the needs of the market and
then the prices adjust accordingly and
so you might say well what are the the
positives and negatives that people
generally associate with command
economies or market economies well the
motivation that's often given for a
command economy is some notion of
fairness or some notion of equality that
when you have an a market economy as a
byproduct of this mechanism where
different people are competing some
people are innovating more or less some
people might be working harder or less
some people might just get lucky or
unlucky er you naturally will have some
level of inequality and some of the
original ideas behind command economies
like communism where hey we don't like
this inequality we want to see more
fairness and so we want to see everyone
get exactly the same car we want to see
everyone get exactly the same number of
apples we don't want to see all of these
competing firms we want one really big
efficient factory to just turn out these
cars now it turns out in reality that's
a little bit utopian even at the peak of
some of these communist economies there
were people who had better access to
certain things people who might have
carried favor with the leadership had
more power who had better
Hartman's had better cars had more
access to resources and people who
didn't in a market economy yes there
will be some inequality but the best
thing going for it and the reason why
most economies in the world even ones
that are nominally communist like the
Chinese economy have transitioned to a
market economy because a market economy
is also associated with things like
innovation and strong incentives for
people to innovate or work or do things
think about the situation in a command
economy let's say that you are a manager
at this factor here the government has
pretty told you to produce exactly ten
thousand cars in exactly the type of
model maybe you have an idea for how to
make this car more efficient but no
one's really going to reward you for
that if you're not going to be able to
get paid more so that you can buy more
things you might not be as interested in
doing it while in this situation you
have extreme competition where as soon
as this factory or this company is out
selling this one everyone here is going
to think wow we need to innovate we need
to really work harder so that we can
take more market share from the other
company similarly at the individual
level different people might say hey I
can only afford the yellow car now but I
di really wish I had the blue car so
maybe I'm going to work a little bit
harder or I'm going to try to innovate
or I'm going to try to start a business
most of the world has transitioned to
something much closer to a market
economy because overall even though you
have this inequality it has made more
productivity more innovation more goods
and services available to more people
now the reality is is most economies as
I mentioned they're close to a market
economy but they aren't a perfect market
economy you still have the government
very involved in certain industries in
many economies the government might be
in control of healthcare the government
in almost every country has significant
influence in things like the military
the government and say the United States
which is considered a fairly capitalist
a fairly strong market economy the
government still does offer social
safety nets when the inequality gets too
extreme if someone is in the
Wilda feed themselves they might get
food stamps if someone isn't able to get
health care because of poverty they
might get Medicaid and so there's
actually a spectrum between a command
economy and a market economy with most
economies actually falling in this
in-between state which is sometimes
referred to as a mixed economy for
example as already mentioned the United
States which is considered a very
capitalist country with a market economy
it still does have some public ownership
the government still does control
certain aspects of the economy it still
represents a fairly large chunk of the
economy and so a pure command economy
government would control everything pure
market economy you would have very
little that's controlled by the
government but the reality in most of
the world things fall in this mixed
economy spectrum